DATING BACK TO THE REGULAR
SEASON.
.A. 39-35 IN
GAME ONE.
HERE'S A SHOT PUCK A GAME, BY FT
IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE.
THAT'S A PERFECT PASS T HAD FIV
IN GAME ONE.
FACEOFF VICTORY FOR EDMONTON.
McDAVID ON HIS W
TWO AGAI
THAT'S THE EXTRA DEFENCEMAN
SOMETIMES HE'S BEEN CALLED AS T!
AND JONATHAN QUICK ATE THAT ONE
UP!T YAMAMOTO IS GOING
TO TAKE THAT SHOT.
HE TAKES IT AWAY.PUTS ON THE
MIKE SMITH WITH A GREAT SAVE TY.
LATE ON THAT POWERPLAY. REVERSE
THE CLEANEST
PENALTY KILL BUT EDMONTON GETS
SIDE.R TO
THE BLUE LINE. BAT.
A FACEOFF WON.
THIS ONE ELUDES JONATHAN QUICK.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A CLUE WHERE TO
DRAISAITL WHO FINDS HYMAN.
A PASS.
LOADED UP.
NURSE ACTIVATES AND THIS PUCK
DOES DEFLECT EN ROUTE, GOES OFF
SP SHOTHE
NET!
WHAT A GREAT SAVE ON THAT
AND LIZOTTE'S GOING TO SEND THE
WARREN FOEGELE FROM BEHIND THE
KASSIAN.
LOOK AT THE LAYERS OF SCREENSLO.
THE OILERS MAKING A SOME
UNEXPECT SENDING THE PUCK
ie: CONFIDENT MOVE BY
JESSE PULJUJARVI.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIM PLAYING JUST
OVER 7
AND ALWAYS HAVING A CONVERSATION
WITH SOMEONE.IDDLE TO KANE WHO'S
GOT A CHANCE!
AND HE SCORES!
[ Horn ]
BUT THE SPEED OF EVANDER KANE,
HE GETS HIS STICK ON IT.S, POWE
EVEN STRENGTH, ITT ALL ON
JONATHAN QUICK'S FACE.
GREAT LITTLE POKE CHECK THERE.
THIS
NO ICING HERE AND OLLI MAATTA
MOVING
ICE, THE MOVEMENT, THE
FLEXIBILITY, THE POWER.
LOOK, SAYING IT'S A
TWO-ON-ONE.
YOU'RE UP 6-0 TRYING TO KILL A